[Music]
foreign
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Friday June 9th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
YouTube is a hub for all kinds of video
content everything from music videos to
news broadcasts to live streamed NFL
games but the bulk of its content is
still mostly uploaded by thousands of
independent video producers and YouTube
relies on that to sell advertising so
perhaps it's no wonder that its CEO Neil
Mohan is making an effort to meet and
even bond with some of the platform's
biggest creators but will that be enough
to help YouTube attract content creators
and advertisers at a time of rising
competition
with me to discuss this is Miles Krupa
who covers YouTube and his parent
company Google Miles YouTube has always
attracted a lot of independent content
creators so why is Mohan making this
effort to woo them yeah I mean in some
ways it's more of a competitive
environment than ever in video YouTube
is still this really dominant online
platform but you know I have things like
Tick Tock metas Instagram reels really
taking mind share in some ways away from
YouTube YouTube has always had this
advantage and that you know it pays
about 55 of advertising Revenue out to
the creators of the videos and so far
Tick Tock and Instagram really haven't
been able to mirror that at all but the
amount of reach that creators are able
to get on things like Tick Tock means
that they're attractive for other
reasons and so it's a really fragmented
landscape now and you know everybody
talks now about the multi platform
Creator so right now I think Neil is
trying to sort of make sure that their
YouTube first if they're multi-platform
took over as CEO in February what was he
doing before that before that he was
basically the right-hand man to former
CEO Susan wachitzki and led product so
he helped lead the role out of YouTube
shorts their answer to tick tock he also
oversaw things like trust and safety you
know a few years back YouTube was going
through a really tumultuous period where
there were concerns about the content on
the platform advertisers were revolting
and Susan put Neil in charge of
basically cleaning it up and
establishing new rules for how you
upload content to the platform and
what's allowed and what's not how's he
using that experience now that he's the
boss well I think in many ways he was
already doing what he's doing now in my
interviews with him he sort of framed it
as like nothing's really changed he's
now the top boss but he's still
overseeing product and he hasn't hired
anybody to to be the new Chief product
officer yet he testified in front of
Congress last year that will probably be
a bigger part of his life new
regulations from Europe coming down will
also affect YouTube heavily I want to
talk about one of the important groups
for YouTube the advertisers how is Mohan
dealing with them advertising is
challenging right now YouTube's had a
few straight quarters of basically flat
to roughly negative ad Revenue the Big
Challenge right now is YouTube has been
promoting uh YouTube shorts and so far
advertisers aren't warming as quickly to
short form video as they are to
YouTube's long form stuff
so getting that mix right making sure
that YouTube is monetizing shorts at a
rate at which they can keep paying
creators to want to post short videos
that's sort of the calculus Neils trying
to get right at the moment I think most
people expect the big advertisers to
continue spending on YouTube as the
economy improves right now we're in a
bit of a dip but long term the real
question is can he win them over to this
new short video format in a way that
also satisfies creators the short format
isn't the thing that YouTube has
expanded to though in the last few years
it's also adding this sort of tv-like
content to its platform how's that
paying off for the company yeah I mean
YouTube is quietly built up this really
big presence on televisions in the
living room more and more people are
watching YouTube videos of all kinds on
the TV whether that's things like
YouTube TV it's online Cable Bundle or
things produced by creators like Mr
Beast prank videos stunts
Etc YouTube right now is trying to
really leverage that to
really bump up ads even more on the TV
screen it's still slow going at the
moment I think ad rates compared to
other big TV players are still not quite
there but Neil has been really trying to
make the pitch that this is the new way
people are consuming TV you know they
want a mix of stuff they want user
generated content they want professional
content and younger people especially
are viewing this as the future of TV
watching what does that mean for
competing with platforms like say
Netflix or Amazon Prime when it comes to
ad streaming dollars as those platforms
start to look for advertisers as well
yeah well I think YouTube's pitch just
rests on the fact that they have the
most reach of any of those because they
have the widest variety of content I
think that there's a credible argument
YouTube can make that if you want to get
your ads in front of a lot of eyeballs
YouTube is a really good way to do it
and yet there are still sort of these
lingering concerns around and the
professionalism of the content whether
people are really going to sit through
multiple ads on a YouTube video like
they might do on a Prestige TV show so
it's still a work in progress but I
think YouTube's been working on sort of
building the base to make that pitch to
advertisers for years so what is mohan's
vision for YouTube in the years to come
you know his vision is really leaning in
to all of the different products they've
launched over the past few years he
really stresses that he doesn't want
YouTube to be about one format or
another I think Neil is trying to
maintain a flexible approach based on
what creators are doing and that's why
you see him talking to creators he wants
to know how they're making videos what's
working for them what's not and try to
respond to that that's our reporter
miles Krupa
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week tnb's producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
Tinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]